I take the trigger fingers from all my
prisoners it's less likely to shoot me
in the back
is my business lock them up you are
going to hang for this what happened to
you
see right now
[Music]
dead men strung to Your Wagon those men
threatened to rape my wife
mayor's gonna want to talk to you
[Music]
mayor Thomas where's he at Bishop's
mayor now
hello Roy I missed you by a day in
Galveston three young men are dead there
I didn't kill no one get your facts
straight friend
let's go not today I ain't asking I said
not today I've just been giving news
that my brother was murdered
I'm gonna give you one day in honor of
your brother don't play games with me
get out of town they're gonna string you
up for killing the Man's brother we
gotta get the hell out of here you wanna
join
you win you walk out of here live lose
it's your judgment day show
[Music]
[Applause]
I promise
oh you will pay for this mess you killed
man of the law and there ain't no
clemency for that
Reno's back for Revenge
you bring him to me dead or alive
Bishop's got 50 men securing that mine
tell you four are going to do you can
use your help
back on your horse and let's finish this
Revenge
kill him kid